in every war there's always a place
which comes to represent the heart of
the horror and here in ukraine that
place is mariupol
the south eastern port city has been the
site of the heaviest bombardment in this
war homes hospitals schools have all
been hit
the casualty numbers have been hard to
comprehend by the end of the seventh
week the mayor said that twenty thousand
civilians had been killed
they say we have liberated you
from what we had a good life
the city is an urban wasteland but why
is mariupol so important
vladimir putin has been fixated on
taking the city from the outset but the
russian advance has been met with
remarkable ukrainian resistance the
industrial city holds great strategic
and symbolic value for both sides in
this conflict
capturing mariupol is key to moscow's
military campaign and has major
practical value for russia
they want to secure a land corridor
between the donbas and crimea since
russia's invasion and annexation of
crimea in 2014 less than 30 kilometers
has separated mariupol from the
russian-controlled separatist
territories in eastern ukraine
so if russia wants that land corridor
uniting areas of their control they need
to take the city
as the biggest ukrainian city on the sea
of azov mariupol is also a base for the
ukrainian armed forces and is
effectively the only major port serving
the donetsk and luhansk regions of the
donbass controlling mariupol secures
control of the ukrainian coast on the
sea of azov
during russia's invasion they have
targeted both economic and civilian
infrastructure intending to cause as
much damage as possible mariupol is
vital for ukrainian trade too
it's an industrial center for iron and
steel works manufacturing and shipyards
as the largest trading port in the sea
of azov mariupol is also vital for
ukraine's exports including grain coal
iron steel and heavy machinery
russia knows that controlling this key
port as well as it's important to
industries will put huge economic
pressure on ukraine's government
there is symbolism here too to
understand its significance you need to
look back to previous conflicts between
these two countries
russia seized mariupol when they last
invaded ukraine in 2014
but ukraine managed to recapture it
making the city a symbol of ukrainian
resistance for russia for putin mariupol
lies on land that is historically
russian he insists the city is part of
the motherland the territory which now
runs across eastern and southern ukraine
was once known as navaroisia or new
russia after the russian empire took the
region from the ottoman empire in a
series of wars in the 18th century
russia's historic claim to ukrainian
land was for vladimir putin one basic
justification for the invasion he
insisted that although russia lost the
territory its people remained there
mariupol holds significant propaganda
value for russia
when putin launched the invasion of
ukraine on february the 24th he said his
plan was to demilitarize and denazify
ukraine
his claims that ukraine's government are
nazis who have committed genocide are
not true
but it is a narrative that russia has
pushed for years
mariupol plays into this propaganda
because the city is the base for the
azov battalion a nationalist infantry
unit formed in 2014 by volunteers who
share ultra nationalist views
the roots of this unit are far right and
at least in part neo-nazi
the unit has about a thousand members
who were incorporated into ukraine's
national guard they make up just a
fraction of the ukrainian military but
fit russia's nazi narrative
beyond the strategic and symbolic value
control over mariupol is a huge morale
boost to the victor a russian victory in
mariupol enables putin to give the
impression to the russian population
that they are making progress fulfilling
their military goals of liberation from
nazis
for ukraine the loss of mariupol is a
catastrophe for the people whose home it
was
the fall of mariupol also sends a stark
message to other ukrainian cities the
people here have mounted a determined
resistance but at what cost and where
could be next